is this introduction weird yes it's
if it's it's just a contraction of it
and is then why doesn't that work in
fact why didn't English just do a find
and replace on all the contractions I'm
sure there didn't have been any problems
with that
well how do we understand where the
problems with this I was supposed to
have a brilliant idea here but it
appears it'sn't okay let's expand those
back out that took me about 17 takes to
get right why don't those contractions
work let's talk about it's in that
introductory line it is just a pronoun
doing its job referring to something
that's established earlier or obvious
from Context but what's the
you can't even really say it on its own
it's just kind of leaning on the it for
substance which is why the technical
term for it is clitic from the ancient
Greek and cliticus meaning to lean on
eclitic is a part of speech that can't
exist just on its own now we've talked
about things like this before prefixes
suffixes and other affixes things that
attach to words like Abu or on but
atletic isn't one of those and we know
that because it doesn't attach to
individual words it attaches to a phrase
a bigger part of speech so using a
prefix or affix you can go from a dog to
a Proto dog or an anti-dog or an Astro
Dog or you can say that something is
dog-ish those all attached to the word
dog if you add some detail you say my
beautiful green Astro Dog not my Astro
beautiful green dog that doesn't work
for a clitic it's different my Astro
dog's been learning tricks there's the
clinic just after dog let's add some
more detail my Astro Dog from Jupiter's
been learning tricks that movement of us
within the sentence means it can't be an
affix that behaves like it's the whole
word like it's has not is has all that
means that has to be in its own category
it's a clitic but that doesn't explain
why it doesn't work sometimes if it was
always possible to contract is and has
down like that there might be an
argument that it's just a pregnancy
association thing there has to be some
additional reason that means it'sn't and
yes it's are ungrammatical now if you
want the full answer to that you can
read Anderson's aspects of the theory of
critics but a quick warning it is 287
pages long not including the references
and indices so to summarize as best as I
can for English there are two reasons
the first is what's called a syntactic
gap which means the presence of the
clitic strongly implies that another
word should follow I think Anderson's
best example is
who do you think you're
oh do you think you're what meeting
talking to it it feels like there should
be another word in that syntactic Gap
the clitic is stranded at the end and
flipping that around if you say who do
you think you are meeting the sentence
feels I'm not ungrammatical but maybe a
little awkward and robotic and very much
tied to that is the second reason stress
patterns part of the reason these forms
can be reduced so much is because
they're generally unstressed or weak
they're pronounced more quietly and less
distinctly you cannot stress eclitic and
it sounds weird when you try so let's
try if a child's parent is pestering
them because they haven't cleaned up the
kid can reply I am going to do it that's
called rejoin your emphasis but they
can't say I'm going to do it doesn't
work so if the verb would contextually
be in its weak form unstressed and it
also starts with or a vowel it can get
even more reduced to this clitic form so
we get wheel value viewed iron and so on
repeat enough times they become
grammaticalized and they start to get
written like that as well in theory
something like they didn't have could
work after all shouldn't have is
grammatical in spoken English as in I
shouldn't have done that actually in my
dialect if I'm talking quickly I
pronounce that as either or even just
shouldn't like shouldn't done that
languages change and evolve over time
words become critics can stay that way
for a while and then eventually they may
start to sound ungrammatical to Future
Generations after all we used to say tis
not it's so who knows in a century or
two maybe verdantev will be perfectly
unremarkable English
if you want more detail about this
there's a whole episode on my co-author
Gretchen mcculloch's podcast link
enthusiasm the link is on screen or in
the description